allora siccome fort night è un gioco e
non so giocare a formenti non lo porto
mai ho deciso di portarlo con una
persona che di formez e nintendo un po
più di me misa e quindi ho chiesto a
ciccio di accompagnarmi questa partita
per vedere se riesco a non fare così
schifo ok quindi o il bello è che a tu
non sai che le dune a questo momento
supporto è la categoria di gioco più
difficile in assoluto più difficile da
perfetta l'abbiamo scelto quella giusta
e io non ho armi non ho niente però va
bene niente combattendo io sono vivo
sono più forte io diciamo che non è
andata proprio come indicami solo cosa
dovrei fare in questo momento poi tanto
morirò qui non c'e neppure ricami il
banco fucile non trovava da quelle parti
se come ninja mi guardai ciccio ha posto
ai vinco io no no dai
no ci avevo creduto
not bad not medico torniamo abbattimento
più di me quindi va bene wherever you
want my friends due reti gli uomini
quello che la pasta degna di una
fattoria ma questo è positivo
anch'io come lei decisa in spalla
paracadute sulle spalle l'ex co
paracadute sulle spalle le senza far
aiuterà il schianto elezioni dopo che
atterriamo sollevato quasi la foresta
perché c'è la cassa qua sotto
la foresta e io di mamma mia quanta
gente c'è gente che ti punta state che
sono fucili a pompa
ma come facciamo
ma io nobel ha buttato giù uno allora
non ci sono con la trappola capirla
porca vacca siamo tutti e due per terra
e morto il tipo che un cerchio beccato
di anni va bene fatto un'altra che l'ho
fatta almeno quello
se c'è qualcuno non ti mettere paura e
pia la picconate di questo piccone il
nono posto a casa bravo bravissimo si è
andato il giro notano le armi bra via
palloni ho trovato che i suoi palloni o
per saltare più forte sai qual è il
problema
dimmi quello che tu sei morto e che io
c'ho 6 divida importa mi importano
importato abbiamo raggiunto in tre amici
quando ti butti tu subito subito adesso
sì senza senza anno fa mi punti devi
proprio puntare questa città qua e di là
monti e poi andiamo su quell altra ali
proprio fa6 di sopra io va bene son
tradendo il 18 è un po un po morire io
ti seguo come se fosse un minimo
dobbiamo fare lo faccio perché tanto
quadra
secondo me passerà un po di tempo prima
che ritroviamo qualcuno sicuro al cento
per cento
purtroppo il gioco e così va bene
pertanto è così che cosa gli avevo detto
guarda che in forte e particolare cioè
nel senso tua tv a questo momento
guarda quant'è grande la safe 29 persone
rimaste senza mettere mai senso non ha
senso non ha senso se fai la prima casa
si stima e poi dopo boh non fai pigna è
bravo bravo vabbè ci sta ci sta una
secca però vengo da te tanto quanto
rubato hanno pure fi dato forte qua
ormai si è diventato tipo quello che
annusa per andarla a e senti i cavalli
ma eccoci genova lo so ci aspetta è un
no secondo me non ci hanno chiesto a noi
non ingaggio niente stai tranquillo
parigi ha battuto blu bravo però a
tostato madonna b che avete costruito in
costumi bill e non secondo non morì
massacrato madonna non riesco ad
ammazzarlo manco io cioè che sonda
dell'istanza dovrei solo colpirlo però
mi servirebbe una marina che questo è
bravo io so jouer quindi vengo su conte
anche lui sta sotto bravo ed acqua che è
molto più forte questo epico
questo era bravo questo era preso quasi
quanto me ci quadri ma quasi quanto me
vabbè dai è uno l'hai fatto fuori
l'altro che è ammazzato dove ha suonato
tutto lui ti serve qualcosa bene e ti do
mese provenienti servono munizioni non
ti serve una se.ga mi servono forse
ministri l'assalto e basta quel giorno
ho deciso che non ci ridarà mai tecnico
ho provato a mettere la torretta prima
porteranno la messa credo che noi no
anche a noi quad
questo è successo non lo voglio hai
fatto fuori uno sul quale era lì e no da
solo la stava con il quad stava sopra il
quad amica incredibile che botta salud
quanto questo buono che è molto buono
molto bene gli sci l'inizio non mi dire
perché è morto lui è morto anche il
cuore va bene mi hai fatto un colpo
incredibile
citiamo anche sparavi osservatore
bravissimo senti poi un pompa
leggendario te lo prendo con il legno si
è si chiama di me che non ti voglio bene
mannaia decorarsi e fratello lino per
terra per depositare cosa e come faccio
a bollenti male se spendo del mio
materiale per prenderti una grazia è
vero questa questo vale più di mille
parole
cioè ma veramente
di mille spiegazioni ok allora quindi
sul i maschi siamo abbastanza centrali e
ripetitivo perché poi potremmo passare
per i ripetivi però non è possibile
c'è un conflitto la ma amava ad api alla
fine devi dargli le botte le donne botte
ea delle a un volano è visto
no non fanno più l'albero sì sì vieni ti
reggo stanno venendo sta morendo stato
colpito un bravissimo altri chiedo di
loro da che se rinculano caccia fu la
torretta si propria mannaia 110 blanco
porca vacca che porta ciccio da poi ho
sentita io quello da me porco schifo
però spara linfa
ma tu non sei morto sento anch'io vedo
ancora la vita sono moltissimo va bene
adesso si mormora pace
porca vacca aveva ai camici semiplay
massacrati ma sacrario era un'altra da
chi se ne avrei andata comunque così
comunque non male per questo comunque
ripiano la massima quando mi dici
aiutami
io entro imparano erico gridava aiuto
dove effettivamente parlando doveva
avere un pochino di coraggio in più io e
push hurley però sapevo che il bastardo
ci aveva il lanciarazzi
la gente si sarà cavata agli occhi
guardandomi come sparavo in niente però
chi se ne frega ma guarda che loro erano
full shield full tutto che stavano stato
trovato perché lo colpi di un botto e
ancora è ancora tutta la vita è che
hanno trovato tutti gli sci lì non ci
aveva molti ma noi non abbiamo trovato
niente lo re
niente io vado sullo stesso detto di
prima cos'è un po altino
c'è uno che sta dietro idea arrivo ti do
manforte nominandoci però sono molto
contento per te io non trovo niente se
ne è andato se n'è andato con quei
palloncini un'arma c'è uno era dietro il
muro che ha fatto un culo così ciccio mi
ha fatto un culo quadro sono ancora vivo
ma per poco e qua dentro c'è una carica
delle idee sileci street è bravo e di
atri te fa c'era tutto ancora lì
martino 123456 ma non lo sai che
scrivere un nickname
te la possiamo fare sì ciccio me lo
sento
minchia se me lo sento pia stanno
facendo tra loro ma noi dobbiamo dare
phyton gb colpisco e si se poi si ok non
volevo ingaggiare potevo molto colpirli
dove stanno
eccolo
pur brava mamma mia oh però ho girati
f10 si 60 giorni della gara 4
ma porco demonio porco dagli occhi occhi
occhio sta sparando a pepe ha ucciso
pepe va bene ma al miracolo che si
arriva da top 5 ci sono io provo nei ti
farò diventare un campione di fare chi
summer schermi winter la mamma e basta
che superiamo che con bomba cioè che
supero io canto c'è una persona da
odiare in più spero che venisse
piacevole ragazze mi ha fatto veramente
schifo però è colpa mia non è colpa di
ciccio polo christie's per risultati
assurdo per quanto forma il possa
piacere se lo porto io come quella
parola che non mi a sti cazzi sticazzi
quella la parola spero che ci aiuti ad
essere un momento di piacere in casa cc
per aver partecipato sono sicuri si
chiede riceviamo
[Musica]